so the theme of the debate is whether
the universe began as all our children
are taught in school with a big bang to
discuss this um we're very fortunate to
have on my left
Roger Penrose and now Rogers an Oxford
mathematician philosopher of science
pioneered the mathematics of black holes
you were Hawking's mentor weren't him he
worked with you you should never believe
am i right Sean Carroll cosmologists and
physicists California Institute of
Technology writes regularly for the New
York Times wire New Scientist and if
flora turns up I shall introduce her
might the big bang theory be mistaken
Sean would you like to just start right
so to answer that we first have to say
what we mean by the big bang theory
because this phrase is meant in two very
different contexts right we all know the
universe is expanding so if you run the
clock backwards if you run the film to
the past 14 billion years ago it was in
a hot dense state and we have something
called the Big Bang model of cosmology
which is simply the statement that
fourteen billion years ago the universe
was in a hot dense state it expanded and
cooled and went from being very smooth
to relatively lumpy which it is right
now with all these stars and galaxies
and so forth that's the Big Bang model
it is true there's no point in doubting
the Big Bang model okay we don't let
people up here on stage if they doubt
that part of the Big Bang model but if
you take seriously general relativity
and you say well what happened at the
very beginning what happens so we know
exactly what the universe was doing one
minute after the very beginning of the
Big Bang okay from one minute after 214
billion years after we understand that
first minute is a little bit up for
grabs so classical general relativity
the theory that Einstein gave us for
space and time would say according to
Roger and Stephen Hawking that at that
moment T equals zero at the very
beginning there was a singularity but
there's also this thing called
mechanics which gets in the way which is
not part of general relativity so if you
want to say the big bang event the Big
Bang moment the beginning of everything
we don't know whether that is right or
not we have room as theoretical
physicists and cosmologists to invent
new scenarios and debate over which is
right which is wrong and so that's where
our disagreement comes in I'm pretty
agnostic to be honest about whether or
not that moment because it's a moment in
time the Big Bang not a place in space
it's not an explosion in a pre-existing
space it's the beginning of everything
it's the moment before which there were
no other moments and that's the model
and the question is is that model right
so I I have two favorite theories and
neither one of them is Rogers favorite
theory so that gives us something to
talk about one theory that I think is
very at least on the table as plausible
is yes that is the beginning of the
universe and it's because time and space
themselves are not fundamental that when
you get deep into the guts of quantum
mechanics you realize that all the stuff
around us the tables the chairs space
itself time itself are emergent
approximate phenomena they're like
talking about the air as a fluid with
the temperature and a pressure rather
than talking about the molecules maybe
even time is just a good approximation
and it started 14 billion years ago
that's one possibility that I think is
very plausible the other if time is
truly fundamental if time is real and
they're an inextricable from the
fundamental equations then I think it's
very likely that the Big Bang was not
the beginning in that case but I also
think that as Roger has emphasized
better than anyone there's something
very profound about the nature of time
in our observable universe namely that
it has a direction right that the past
is different from the future and if we
can get into this I hope the reason why
the past is different from the future in
your everyday life the reason why you
remember yesterday and not tomorrow is
ultimately because of what conditions
were like at the Big Bang
that's what set up the arrow of time and
that's the fundamental mystery of
cosmology why was it like
so my favorite view of that is that
there is a much larger universe that we
don't see that our little universe is a
tiny little part of the whole picture
and the whole picture is actually
symmetric that there are people in our
past who think that we are in their past
the time runs in the opposite direction
for them as it does for us this is not
by any means set in stone we don't know
it for sure but these are the kinds of
scenarios that we're talking about as
professional cosmologists to understand
why the universe that we do live in
looks the way it does marvelous so
that's all clear time may not be
fundamental it may be people in your
future looking at you in their past or
something the way around
marvelous okay Roger and are you gonna
make it worse or better and that's a
good question well you see Shaun didn't
mention the thing that I was really
going to disagree about according to
conventional theory okay the Big Bang
this is big mystery and what was it and
did quantum mechanics have an important
role to play and what was going on well
the dress that question in the moment
but there was supposed to be something
within the first ten to the minus thirty
two seconds now what does that mean you
think of a number one fraction the
bottom the denominator is a number which
has 32 digits and that fraction
ridiculously small fraction of a second
the universe was supposed to have
expanded far more rapidly than anything
that we're aware of now it's called an
exponential expansion which is supposed
to taking place and that's called
inflation and it is very much part of
conventional cosmology now to me that's
the weak point of conventional cosmology
because you have to introduce ideas
which there's no other reason for apart
from making it do this but apart from
that if you go one blip after that I
completely agree with what Sean soon so
the argument has to be what from before
that and I'm claiming that although
there was this idea of a steady state
model which
grew up with I may say when I was in
Cambridge as a graduate student this was
all going on and Denis Sharma was a good
friend of mine and Bondi and gold and
people I used to know fred hoyle
and they were all dead keen on this idea
that the universe went on expanding
expanding and it didn't change much
because new matter was created all the
time okay I like that theory because
philosophically it meant there was no
beginning and you could talk about the
universe in that kind of way now I'm
picking up on that in a different way
though I'm not disagreeing with a Big
Bang there was a big bang I am rather
disagreeing that quantum mechanics was
important there and that's a big point
of difference really the reason that
you're allowed to continue before the
Big Bang which was what I'm trying to
claim is because in a certain sense I'm
agreeing is shown that you don't have
time how do we measure time we have
extraordinarily accurate clocks today
because a particle of mass is really a
clock and this based on the two basic
most famous formula of 20th century
physics namely Einsteins equals MC
squared which tells you energy and mass
equivalent and Max Planck's equals H nu
or F whatever call it which tells you of
energy and frequency equivalent put the
two together that tells you that mass
and frequency are equivalent that tells
you that if you have a massive particle
it is a clock of extraordinary precision
now the point is when you don't have
massive particles and this would apply
to the remote future when basically the
universe is dominated by photons running
around either from stars or from black
holes you see Stephen Hawking his most
famous discovery if you like or a
theoretical discovery was that black
holes are not completely black or
they're not completely cold that they
have a temperature that temperature is
so low that it's much lower than
anything who built in the lab certainly
with the big biggest black holes sun
galaxy has a black hole in its center
which is about 4 million times the mass
of the Sun that's so cold that it puts
everything else in the shade now the
thing is the record of Hawking the
things eventually will evaporate away
because the universe gets colder than
the black holes they evaporate away and
disappear so when those have disappeared
there's nothing left but things which
don't have any mass there's the photons
basically that's true and that they're
the only way of you don't have clocks
anymore because you don't have mass and
so the remote future you have no way of
keeping time and the idea is that this
remote future where you have this
expansion of the universe which is
becoming exponential expansion which is
what we currently observe continues
forever now I found that a really
depressing picture it seems to me you
know the universe is pretty exciting now
but then you eternity of boredom but
then I thought who's gonna be born I'll
not ask her we won't be around the main
things will be out there photons and
it's very hard to borrow photon I'll
tell you because photons the main reason
is probably they don't experience
anything but that's not the point the
main point is that they don't measure
time photons right up to infinity and
they're still there and they said what
what what you've got to do with the
universe they're still there the idea is
that the universe continues with what I
call another Eon hour Eon started with a
big bang and ends with this exponential
expansion that then becomes the big bang
of another Eon and there was an eon
before I could go and talk for endlessly
this if you allow me but the beginning
there was an and now that Rogers got
that clear for you Lara has turned out
so now it will get what right so laura
mercier Houston cosmologists professor
of physics and focuses on the multiverse
so we had a universe we've got a long
line of them one out of the other and
now we're gonna have more universes and
you can shake a stick out might the Big
Bang Theory be mistaken it's a shame to
ask you such as more question before you
put your breath
but please it is not wrong and by Big
Bang I mean cosmic inflation it is not
wrong it's incomplete it tells us all we
want to know from the moment the
universe comes into existence the
present day it agrees exquisitely well
with observations but it creates its own
problem of the origin what it came from
this is your first split that tiny
moment yeah exactly well I mean maybe we
didn't really talk about inflation will
get seems like a very short introduction
do you want to say so yeah
cosmic inflation gives us this beautiful
picture were the large-scale structure
in the universe and the Cosmic Microwave
Background basically everything we
observe around us he seeded from those
primordial quantum fluctuations and how
the whole universe started small and
stretched all its non-uniformities as
cosmic inflation made that universe to
accelerate and grow big very quickly so
we have a set of observations our
precision cosmologies is a very advanced
field by now so all our observations
will agree perfectly well with this
picture of cosmic inflation it does not
mean they prove cosmic inflation it's
conceivable that someone else might come
along with a different picture that also
agrees with this set of observations
however we are happy because here is a
theory that tells us everything from the
first fraction of a second to
present-day and we know our universe
started small and it's growing but that
picture does not tell us what gave that
first energy and what was there before
and not lies beyond our universe is
about 10 to the power 27 centimeters the
visible universe and it's only 13.8
billion years old these are big numbers
but they are not in conceivably big so
we all of us have the right to ask what
was there thirteen point nine billion
years ago or what was there at what's
beyond 10 to the power 27 centimeters
okay
so um we've got a great story but we're
missing the first paragraph in this
story it says that that bit got torn off
so you've got a great story from then on
but you don't know what happened right
at the beginning the first page um well
then our our first question really is do
we have to have a beginning I mean it's
nice to have one all stories start with
once upon a time and do we need one do
we need a first cause or are some
scientists happy that we don't have one
and it is our preference for having a
beginning because you lot have inherited
that that sort of myth structure from
from Christianity I mean I don't think
the engines are too worried about this
yes Oh Jeff do you think we we we have
to have a beginning or is it just a an
article of faith well currently my
scheme does not have a beginning but the
beginning that we think of as the Big
Bang was the continuation of something
which didn't look like a Big Bang but
wasn't it previously expanding what I
call an eon and these went on as far as
the theory goes indefinitely so there
was no beginning in this scheme of
course that might not be right but I
think there are some observations very
recent observations which I don't see
how you can explain on the basis of
current inflationary theory and I rather
disagree about inflation being a nice
beautiful theory it's a very artificial
theory well you have to introduce
concepts which are invented just before
we get on to that when you say an eon
have I got the right picture that
basically is saying before our universe
our current what there was before it yes
and it sort of came to an end and then
there's another one it's an old idea
that the universe expanded and then
collapsed again so we're just sensing
with beginnings and endings well let me
just go back to the old idea see this
was one of the very old originally right
after Einstein produced his theory three
months of the equations and one of the
solutions was
which expanded and collapse like this
and it went through these phases no this
is very different because it never
collapses and that's what people have
trouble swallowing you see how can this
universe which is expanding getting
rarefied cold and all that become this
Big Bang which is very hot and
compressed and they look completely
different but they're not completely
different if you don't have mass because
it's a funny idea but in this model when
you don't have clocks around which you
don't when you don't have mass then
they've in small become equivalent it's
what you call conformal equivalent large
things and small things you can't tell
them apart if you don't have a scale
which tells the difference and the scale
gets lost when you don't have particles
with mass and so when that scale is lost
this expanding indefinitely expanding
universe becomes a big bang of the next
even though it was very large one spot
yes when you see lose track of what
large means when you've only got photons
running around there's no meaning to
saying it's larger small the equations
become identical I agree it's a hard
idea to swallow and it's lanky Roger of
YouTube willing to swallow this ID or
would you rather look like you you want
to say something in terms of your
question can we do with universe that
didn't have a beginning certainly we can
but we observe that that's not the case
with our universe we know our universe
at the beginning so we don't get to have
a choice on that and in terms of the
theory of cosmic inflation explaining
many of the features we observe in our
universe I did state before that it's a
beautiful and natural theory that's true
except that it has a very very unnatural
feature which is the one that Roger
pointed out in the 70s I believe that
the chance of starting the universe
with high energy inflation is incredibly
small it's 1 to the power 10 and we've
had this discussion and and in that
sense yes I completely agree with Roger
that that's a very unnatural beginning
to have a very special beginning to have
but that argument is a consequence of
the second law of thermodynamics we can
turn it around and say our universe
study started at an incredibly small
entropy or at an exquisitely ordered
state at a very special state so always
give the problem of the origin of the
universe whether it's via cosmic
inflation or via some other mechanism or
some other theory that problem will
always be tied up with the issue of the
second law of thermodynamics by which
entropy always grows so whatever
beginning we can conceive of in the
future the entropy of that state would
have grown so that beginning would will
always be special relative to some final
state and and that is the part where I'm
not sure I agree with Roger any further
I I like his his theory of eons and and
cycles in the universe but I have not
thought carefully on how that evades the
second law of thermodynamics whether you
can have such a theory whether you don't
lose information in each cycle I think
it's an absolutely key point yeah
absolutely right the answer to it
according to my scheme goes lands us in
another one of these big controversies
it has to do with black holes see the
entropy in our universe right now is
almost uh turley dominated by black
holes and so what happens to us black
holes well they evaporate away by
hawking of aberration and then you have
to take a view which is not so normal
see people tend to think that somehow
the information is going to come back
black holes but I say no this is there
were two Hawking's the Hawking you put
forward this theory first about her
black hole evaporation who said
information was lost there's the second
Hawking who changed his mind and said no
information somehow got to backing it
back again I think he was right the
first time he was right the first time
information is lost and it's because the
information is lost that you allow all
that information and the entropy does is
involved in that and you start again by
with what's left and that's how you
satisfy the second law so it does make
sense as far as I know the scheme I'm
proposing is the only one I know of at
least which you get this very uniform
gravitation free as degrees of freedom
in the gravity gravitational field not
there in the next Eon so it starts clean
all over again and it makes sense with a
second law and I don't know of any other
scheme which does that well let's ask
Sean I actually do have a scheme talk
about that or we could back up a little
bit cuz you still have this well I'm
just do you think we need the beginning
well yeah I mean you sort of like opened
a little bit of a door to saying you
know does the University to creator to
make this something right so well it's
early in the morning we muscle push some
hot buttons just to get people wait
right so we have a whole bunch of
different scenarios for the very very
long scale evolution of the universe
some of which are eternal time goes from
minus infinity to plus infinity some of
which are finite the universe has not
only a beginning but an end and some of
which are halfway right the universe has
a beginning but not an end in fact that
last one even though it's the weirdest
is kind of the running working model for
most respectable cosmologists today and
so you can ask in the context of any of
these what else is there to be explained
other than what the universe is doing
right there's a sense in which there's a
philosophy which I don't necessarily
agree with but you can say science says
what the universe does it doesn't say
why the universe does those
so in particular you might think that
there's a very big difference in the
explanatory burden if the universe has a
beginning versus when it doesn't if you
were Isaac Newton if you believed in
classical mechanics the universe just
lasts forever
right time is absolute and it just goes
on forever
Newton actually was a little bit worried
about the implications of that Newton
thought that God would come in and
rearrange the planets occasionally
because otherwise they would they would
run off and later Pierre Simone applause
made fun of him for that loss of courage
and just believing the universe could
run all by itself but then once general
relativity comes along with Einstein you
can show that if the universe is full of
stuff it's either expanding or
contracting so there was probably a
crunch or a bang right there was a
beginning or an end and one of the first
people who take this seriously was a a
priest
George lameta and he developed his
theory of the primeval atom which we
would now call the Big Bang and he said
you know several billion years ago
everything was on top of everything else
maybe the universe contra Newton had a
start right and you know who loved this
idea was the Pope the Pope said all
right good I'm gonna put you on a
commission then you can write a paper
that science is proven that God created
the universe now right and lumetri said
no I do not want to do that I don't want
to cuz let Metra was a smart cookie you
know he knew this is the 1920s he knew
like you know we don't have the final
answer now we can't write a document
that says prove that God created the
universe because it had a beginning
because some smart cosmologists is gonna
come along as head it doesn't have a
beginning right someday in the future so
but nevertheless there's this thought
that if the universe is eternal it could
be self-sustaining they could just be
self-contained and all by itself whereas
if it had a beginning there needs to be
a cause for its creation and I would say
that even then that's not right this is
one of the wonderful consequences of
this way of thinking about the
intersection of quantum mechanics and
gravity that Stephen Hawking others have
pursued is that even a universe with the
beginning can be fully self-contained
that's a description of the universe
just because it has a first moment in
time does not require anything outside
to push the button and get it started
you shouldn't think of even if the Big
Bang is the beginning let me just say
parenthetically all these different
scenarios we're talking about are
unlikely to be true okay cuz we don't
know the right answer but Roger scenario
my scenario Laura's scenario none of
these have a better than 10% chance each
a being final answer right so if it does
turn out to be true that the universe
had a beginning you shouldn't think of
it as there was nothing necessar
it's very hard to not think of that way
cuz the flow of time is embedded in how
we think about the world and you think
about well if there was the Big Bang
then it came from nothingness but there
wasn't a nothingness that turned into
the Big Bang that's the wrong way of
thinking think about it from the other
side there was a first moment of time in
the history of the universe and just
because there was that doesn't mean
there was some reason why it happened so
it's reasonable that's right you know I
would I would sadly I would have you
know Roger mentioned the disappointing
idea that the universe will last for
infinity years in the future and we'll
all be dead it's also kind of
disappointing to say well why did the
universe exist at all and the answer is
it just did stop asking questions like
that yeah see you're disappointed not
addicted yeah I am disappointed um how
there are alternatives to the Big Bang
we should consider I mean does the
multiverse help and does eons help or we
just left with the same problem picking
up words on death the origin of the
universe question whether it at the
beginning or or not is very closely
related to another fundamental problem
and one that's even harder and that's
the nature of time because we were so
deliberately waiting our hands and
speaking of time before the Big Bang and
time after this and after and before
that but we don't know whether time is
fundamental or it emerged with the
universe itself so unless we have a
better understanding of that issue
probably what was there before the Big
Bang does not make sense do we need a
multiverse I I believe so for many
reasons the first one
we know by observations that our local
universities have a beginning so that
that immediately implies that there is
something else beyond detergent and
before that particular beginning if with
the caveat that that time exists before
our universe did so in that case of
course I did it's hard to believe in a
cosmos with with an eternal time with
the fundamental time parameter that the
only thing that ever happened for
eternity was just one pop our universe
and nothing else so it's quite natural
that one would expect many structures to
twigs is beyond the structure of our
universe and that is a extension of the
Copernican principle we're simply saying
not long ago we thought planet Earth is
the center of the universe and then the
solar system and now we are saying even
our local universe is not the center of
the cosmos were just one humble member
somewhere in in a vast beautiful and
complex cosmos so that that to me makes
sense
the other reason why I over a decade ago
took this idea of the multiverse
seriously is because whenever you you
probe these questions of the origins why
did we start with this universe the kind
of question that Roger asked when I
calculated the probability to start with
such a universe that question does not
make sense if you don't have an ensemble
a pool of possibilities from which to
choose from if all I all I have in my
pocket is I don't know ten pounds then
it does not make sense for me to ask
what's the probability that if I put my
hand in my pocket I'll pull some other
note that is not 10 pounds of course
there is a hundred percent probability
that the only thing that will come out
is 10 pounds and nothing else and and
the same with the universe if you insist
that we must have only one universe then
I I do not see how the question why did
we start with this universe can make
sense and and that if you dig deeper
that that really boils down to two very
fundamentally different approaches to to
the nature of our universe in
theoretical physics one is the approach
of the theory of everything
a single universe and underlying theory
were that of course ideal you can write
on a t-shirt but an underlying theory
that tells you absolutely everything you
need to know about this universe
alternative approach is the multiverse
the possibility that the cosmos is more
complex more there are more structures
we besides our universe and and
depending and and the second that the
latter also allows for an indeterminate
ik universe one that is based on own
probabilities and the first one is based
on a deterministic universe so these two
very different tastes to physics also
determine the kind of one universe
versus many universes approach but
whichever way people coming eventually
will all be forced as we solve one
problem after another after another
we'll all be forced to merge into one
point of view and and and hopefully that
will happen soon Roger isn't the
multiverse enough why do we need eons as
well well let me make clear about the
distinction here you see when people say
multiverse you're thinking in what you
might call parallel you think of a more
stacked up next to each other but the
point of view that I'm pulling for was a
sequential so they're one after the
other and they were really very
different now there are reasons that
some people put forward which are worth
taking seriously that there might be
parallel universes and these have to do
with apparently coincidental constants
of nature and so on which allow life as
we know it to come about now I think
these are arguments one is look at and
take seriously I don't get completely
persuaded by them because it more or
less tells you that life as we know it
couldn't come about unless these numbers
were right but if these numbers have
different values may be a different
completely different kind of life that
we have no experience of and here's
where science fiction is very useful I
mean there's a lovely book by Robert
forward which describes life on a
neutron star and their processes go on
millions and millions of times faster
than ours it's a wonderful story because
you have to relate human timescales to
them to the timescales of the Chi
these creatures I think it's a wonderful
exploration of how life could be so very
different for those arguments it's an
interesting question I think I'm
confused but even if the universities
have I don't have the arguments about
the existence of life and and
fine-tuning of the constants of nature
life arises as we know it in our
universe even that argument is not
correct there there's a lot of work tons
I've looked at some of those with
collaborators Fred Adams and Stephon
Alexander where we show that you can
vary the fine-structure constant
responsible for electromagnetic
interactions and a Newton's constant by
six orders of magnitude and still get
life as we know it in fact and I still
get life as we know it I mean in fact
[Laughter]
this constant stake in our universe make
our universe not right at the center of
the most favorable region for life to
arise we're somewhere in the corner so
the arguments that that we have
fine-tuning and there there is one
universe or or there is a new trend
known as the multiverse research has
taken off there is a new trend of
anthropic dressing of the multiverse
saying oh well if you have so many
possible universes in this multiverse
then the the one we really care about is
the one that allows life and that's
because then we can witness it but now
that we know that you don't need to
fine-tune the constants of nature life
can arise in many but you would still
need a beginning in the multiverse I
mean the multiverse now well each of
those universes have have a beginning
yeah each of them but you have an
infinite number of them right and they
are not parallel parallel universes
refer specifically to something that
that song writes a lot about that's the
interpretation the many-worlds of
quantum mechanics so that that's a very
specific do we do you agree that we
don't need a beginning with the universe
because you admitted there was a little
you know the man's it's the conventional
story is that there's a man on the floor
and he's dead but we didn't actually see
what happened right we don't need the
beginning me being the operative word
there it may be that the Big Bang was
the beginning as Roger has emphasized
for many years now the observed fact is
that our early universe is very very
special if you took all the different
ways you could arrange all the photons
and particles of matter in the universe
the one that we actually have for the
our observed Big Bang is extraordinarily
unlikely
that's these ten to the ten to the
hundred and twenty something unlikely
and so either that was a tremendous
accident and we got lucky nobody
believes that or there's a reason why
that's something that does seem to
demand a reason why maybe it's because
it was the best it was the simplest
right Roger
has the idea of the cycles and the eons
is another one so let me let me actually
try to defend this idea of inflation
that has been remarked upon a couple
times
inflation seems like a cheat visa fee
this particular problem because the
problem is why is universe so unlikely
inflation is a theory where you start in
a particular kind of state and then it
expands and cools and very naturally
becomes the universe that we see but
that place you started as Laura already
said is even more unlikely so that
doesn't seem to help the reason why it
might help is because even though it's
unlikely in this sort of sense of all
the possible ways the universe could
start it is maybe makeable in a way that
the ordinary universe is not if you see
the universe that is all around us with
two trillion galaxies in the observable
universe and you wind that clock
backwards until you hit the point at
which quantum gravity is unavoidable
right the the closest thing we can come
to the beginning of the universe and you
don't believe in inflation everything we
see around us was this big it was about
one centimeter across you might think if
you're not a highly trained professional
cosmologists that's very small yep but
if you are like that's huge because
you're comparing it to sub atomic scales
the size of atoms and particles so you
needed a universe that was perfectly
smooth and regular across a centimeter
when all the particles that we know
about are much much much smaller than
that what inflation lets you do is start
the universe much much much smaller than
that
so if you have a theory for how
universes are created such as my
favorite theory of baby universes where
you start with a big empty universe and
there's a quantum fluctuation that
bubbles off a little bubble of space
that grows into our universe the little
bubble of space that you make is much
more likely to be small than to be big
and if you want to start with a small
universe and make a big one like ours
inflation does a very good job so I
think there can be a role for inflation
whether or not it's true I'm not sure
ten percent right but nevertheless it
does serve eight an obvious purpose that
we might like to take advantage of in
understanding why we started from
someplace very special and got the
verse we see we are fundamentally out of
time
and we can't run it backwards or get it
from any other universe I'm afraid and
so really all it remains is for me to
ask you to join me in thanking our
panelists
[Applause]